ah here we go uh my name is Eden happy
to be here
um I'm going to talk about automation of
gray testing using visual regression
testing and I know it sounds like quite
a handful uh and maybe a little bit
scary uh but after this talk uh
hopefully you have understood how easy
and Powerful it can actually be
so uh here's a problem that I often come
across uh when I work with the UI
how do I test that something is visually
correct
I'm a full stack developer and when
working in backend it's pretty easy I
just
write tests that assert something you
have inputs to functions this function
does something and you get something
back maybe it's inside the fact as well
but you just check that the output is
correct
uh for front ends on the other hand the
output in the end it's visual
it's a UI so of course you might be able
to use react or or just plain HTML HTML
or css so just
get this
tree Dom tree and you might check that
the Dom tree looks correct like code
wise or markup wise
uh but you really don't know if it's
gonna look like on the right here
even if you write tests front-end tests
you might write tests uh but they are
all
usually like time consuming pretty
boring to write and they get out of the
really easy when you start to change uh
the Dom tree
so
um
you could of course uh
solve this by doing a lot of manual
testing just clicking around but if
you're any anything like me uh you would
like to automate things
so
not only the ultimate things but maybe
do them even better
and here's where visual regression
testing comes in uh often just it's
called or shortened to visual testing
which I will do it's a different type of
testing that solves this problem and
other problems I'll start by introducing
the concepts and then also an example of
an end test using playwright and where I
use the tool Percy for the visual
difference checking
and reviews
so first what is visual testing so
instead of doing a search like for
example accept expect something to be
something we actually capture visual
snapshots which you can think of as like
still pictures of
um the UI when you take them
the visual snapshots are taken at the
same place for every time you run the
tests and each actions of the snapshots
they get that unique name
that is really used for each run
so when we then run the same test
multiple times
our visual testing tool person in this
case compares the new snapshots to the
old snapshots
and present you with any changes made
so if there are any visual changes we
can notify the developers and they can
review them and then with either an
approval these are changes I want or
rejections these aren't supposed to be
here
so let's do an example so let's say I'm
a member of the NDC crew and as a git
developer I want to be sure that the
design design layout and content of the
home page to NDC is the way I intended
that it looks the same
it acts the same
even uh when someone makes changes to
other parts of the NDC page maybe the
tickets under on the page or whatever
so basically I just want to test that
the home page looks correct
so of course I want to automate this so
what I do is that I write the test in
playwright so playwright for those who
don't know it's end-to-end testing
library that actually opens headless
browsers to actually do the actions and
normal user would do so it runs the
whole application end to end
so here in this test it starts it's
quite easy it just starts going to the
NDC homepage and then it waits until
everything is loaded
and when that is complete uh Percy comes
in
I call the person snapshot function with
the name of the snapshot
and it takes the snapshot of the
homepage fully loaded and that's
basically it that's the whole test it's
two lines
so when I actually run this uh the first
time Percy gives me a link to their
software version service so I can just
go in there and see the results
and this is how it looks like
so you can see here that uh Persia has
actually taken a snapshot of the page
and it seems pretty correct to me
and that's good
right
so uh as with all other software people
makes changes all the time there will be
changes so here uh I've made like a fake
pull request to make changes to another
part of the NDC website
totally independent from the home page
but suddenly I get this
red x mark from Percy telling me that
one visual change that needs review but
why I edited a completely different part
of the page so why what's the difference
so to find out I just go into the Percy
at this new snapshot the new build
and
I can now compare the new and old
snapshots directly and also person gives
me option to toggle like show the
differences in Red so you can see
exactly what has been changed and you
can see here that I accidentally might
have or written some CSS that is global
that is also on the home page not only
the page I was working on and the whole
ticket menu and endpoint disappeared
completely
so
um I'm sure many of you have had uh
maybe not as extreme this is just an
example but uh issues where you have
changed something and something
something completely different changes
as well
um so now you see how powerful this is I
wrote two lines of code two lines of
tests and I get all this so anytime
there is a change on the NDC homepage
Percy notifies me I don't have to change
the test at all if it's something that
shouldn't be like this
I reject the reject the pull requests
and the developer has to change and fix
this or if it's intended maybe I wanted
to have it like this then I can just
approve it and it's the new uh
the new source of Truth so it will be
used as the Baseline for all new
snapshots
so what can we do next
um I would do a similar test for all
important parts of your page
just some simple tests go to this web
this sub page take a snapshot
it's super quick to make and uh
you get so much value just from it I
call this visual smoke testing secondly
uh
you can set this up to work with you can
test it in different browsers all major
browsers mobile devices different screen
sizes and I heard firstly I actually
supports native mobile apps as well now
and lastly integrate with CI and GitHub
like I showed in the previous slides
make it a part of your whole development
process
get it in your reviews
so three quickly three challenging
challenges that I have seen multiple
times
firstly live dates
if you have live dates in your
screenshots
um they will change every day and you
will get tons of false positives so try
to mock them or freeze them or anything
like that or just hide them secondly uh
wait till the page is fully loaded you
don't want to have like an animation of
loading the page sometimes and sometimes
a fully loaded page just ensure that
it's fully loaded and then you don't
have to worry about flaky and 10 tests
and Flaky snapshots lastly uh try to
avoid using it on a live environment
because things can't change that it's
not in your control maybe someone added
some content to the CMS or
something else changed so you get
snapshot changes that didn't really come
from code changes in your PR
so this is actually a little fun part
while I was making this
um
I had the issue with the Percy always
telling me that someone something was
different and that was this funny thing
the partner over you so apparently
probably to be like fair to all the
partners when you load the page every
time they Shuffle the
Partners so a new partner is going to be
first in the sliding thing every time
and of course then I get a thing down
there because uh
it's changed and actually you have
animation here as well but that's not
the problem because Percy and other
tools they actually freeze all enemy
animations for you so you don't have to
worry about it
so in summary uh the most important
takeaways uh
I would say testing UI code is tedious
you have often have programmatic tests
that's break easily and you need to do a
lot of manual testing to kind of be
comfortable with new changes in a big
complex front end
and visual testing
which takes visual snapshots and
Compares them over time
hereby using Percy
can help here
and you can add them to new end-to-end
tests or existing and tests if you want
and lastly the best way to quickly get a
lot of value from this is to just make
visual smoke tests which are go to the
website important parts of your web
application and just take snapshots
and you're done
yeah and I'm done
thank you
so if there is any questions afterwards
just find me in the I think I'm the only
one with the non-like gray or white uh
clothing here so you will probably find
me